this is Devonte Chisholm reading for
Mark Delaney if you haven't heard by now
the Farm Sim genre that gave us Classics
like Animal Crossing and stardew Valley
is getting a new entry soon Disney Dream
like Valley is in large part exactly
what it sounds like a house of mouse
spin on the popular genre where
characters such as Isabelle and Tom Nook
are replaced by Princess Jasmine and
Scrooge McDuck however Disney dreamlike
Valley is more than just Animal Crossing
dressed in Mickey Mouse ears so we're
breaking down ways in which this new
entry to the genre puts its own spin on
things
perhaps the most important difference
between the two games is that Disney
Dream like Valley is a free-to-play game
when it comes to PC switch Xbox and
Playstation platforms this September
there won't be a price barrier between
fans and the new Disney Experience
Gameloft also made sure to ease tensions
for players who might expect the
typically mobile-centric team to use
more Mobile gaming tactics such as
paying to speed up in-game timers or
buying resources for cooking or building
none of that will be in this game
instead it will feature optional paid
Cosmetics like clothing which will be
available alongside free options too I
also expect some sort of season pass
structure with a premium path that will
reward more Disney themed goodies to
players who buy into it though we're
still waiting to hear more about that
Disney Dream Life Valley is to a great
extent a casual life Sim that lets you
fill your in-game days with whatever you
want to focus on in that time however
there's a whole other section that
involves more story driven levels and
character interactions that don't really
have an equal in Animal Crossing with
dreamlike Valley's Realms you're
transported to various Disney Worlds
such as Remy the rats restaurant from
Ratatouille moana's sunny beaches and
Wally's post eco-apocalyptic planet in
each realm you will complete missions
for the heroes and villains native to
that story land complete their missions
and you'll be able to recruit them to
your neighborhood where they'll
instantly become your new neighbor it's
an interesting Twist on the new neighbor
element of Animal Crossing and Gameloft
said new Realms will be added to the
game often and for free
you start the game with a few neighbors
like Mickey Mouse and Goofy and over
time you see the town filled with new
faces one exciting wrinkle to this very
animal crossing-like aspect is that each
Neighbor comes with their own reward
tree the more you hang out with your
neighbors complete their missions or
give them gifts such as homemade food or
clothing the more they'll appreciate
your companionship you can see previews
of the items you'll get from each of
them each time you level up and with 10
levels for each character in The build I
saw there was a lot worth chasing not
only do you get a hefty Bounty of coin
rewards for spending at Scrooge mcduck's
store but you also get Cosmetics themed
around each character the game seems
full of rewards to keep players invested
and just as long as they keep the Toy
Story Cosmetics coming I'm definitely
invested
let's be honest Animal Crossing didn't
really get the post launch support that
you might have expected from one of the
biggest games in the world in 2020.
Disney Dream like Valley isn't out yet
so it could go a different way but right
now at least game loss intentions seem
to include supporting the game closely
and often it makes perfect sense given
the free-to-play nature of it in
addition to Free Realms and new Disney
properties debuting in the game
regularly the team said players can
expect expansions big and small surely
this means things like new Cosmetics at
the very least but can we expect Star
Wars and Marvel to move into the valley
sometime in the future according to the
dev I spoke to they aren't ruling it out
though there aren't currently any signs
of terraforming like in New Horizons
Disney dreamlike Valley does build on
Nintendo's giant Town customization
options in a major way like Animal
Crossing you can move your home in
Disney dreamlike Valley but what's
interesting here is you can do that
whenever you like for no money at all
want more of a beachfront property just
drag and drop your house to the shore in
the game's build mode as Remy come to
town but you'd prefer his house to be
next to yours rather than scars just
swap them the feature isn't limited to
just you and your belongings every fence
potted plant signpost home and more can
be moved Wherever Whenever you like this
should give players new and old to the
genre quite a thrill as it really opens
up the customization options for
decorating the town precisely to your
heart's desire the same can be said
about clothing if you don't like a piece
of clothing you can customize it with an
intricate layering tool that allows you
to add stamps logos and paint your own
fashion sense right into your wardrobe
your starting area in dream life Valley
is roughly the size of the Animal
Crossing town but it gets bigger over
time as you complete missions you'll
unlock new biomes inspired by different
climates like Jungles and deserts as
well as Brands like Frozen and The Lion
King this gives the setting a lot more
visual variety and when combined with
the customization options really allows
you to theme your Valley exactly as
you'd like want to put all The Lion King
characters in the planes to match the
theme you can like the Friendship
rewards and new Realms new biomes are
just another carrot on the stick for
players who want to be rewarded for
playing
in Animal Crossing food has a number of
uses you can sell it ship it to a friend
place it on a shelf or most importantly
you can eat it for Extra Strength when
tackling a heavy task like breaking a
rock or digging up a tree however you
can easily carry out your day-to-day
tasks without ever touching food in
dreamlike Valley eating actually
restores your stamina bar when you're
out working the feels the mines are down
at the pond all day you're liable to get
fatigue eating food fixes that issue
quickly and easily for when you're in
need and if you're worried about having
to manage this system my pre-launch
experience suggests that there's nothing
to worry about not only is it easy to
refill your energy using Basic Foods
like apples that are growing around town
but if you're totally out of food you
can refill your energy by simply heading
into your house for a moment to
immediately replenish your stamina
there's no need to sleep or step away
from the game
so we've already mentioned the game's
two main modes of play the Freedom Farm
Life Sim and the adventure mode that
takes you into new Realms but there's
also a third story line going on all the
time it revolves around what the
characters call the forgetting in Disney
Dream Live Valley the forgetting was an
event that seems to have wiped
everyone's memories and left dangerous
nightthorns scattered across the land as
the protagonist you show up after it's
taken place and part of your purpose is
to get to the bottom of what it was and
why it occurred while your first order
of business may be obsessively clearing
the night Thorns from each patch of
grass as you find them they represent a
deeper mystery the biomes I mentioned as
well as other landmarks around town are
covered in this Sinister darkness and
while you're not exploring Realms
cooking or designing your own outfits
this forgetting will be a long lasting
mystery that you can dive into by
finding memories around the world or by
completing missions to remove its toxic
influence
Disney Dream like Valley launches in
Early Access for free on September 6th
in a rare feat it's not just hitting PC
via steam Early Access it's also landing
on switch Xbox One series X and S PS4
and PS5 all on the same day and optional
Founders pack will be available at
launch and Xbox game pass ultimate
subscribers will get it as one of their
membership perks though its contents
have yet to be revealed I for one can't
wait to pour more hours into this game
but let me know in the comments if
you're excited for it and stick to
Gamespot for the latest on dreamlife
Valley and more
[Music]
foreign
[Music]